I'm Jason Aldean and my favorite movie
of all time his Field of Dreams first
time I saw Field of Dreams I was about
12 years old and I was infatuated with
baseball and so I fell in love with a
movie the first time I saw it and
probably watched it 500 times since then
to me it's one of those movies that once
I start watching it I don't want to stop
oh so Iowa a few years ago we were out
on the road we were in Iowa where they
filmed this movie and went hung out out
there ran around the field a little bit
got a t-shirt coffee mug you know from
the place and it was just it was a cool
cool deal to go there and see the field
for the first time and still to this day
I mean the grass is perfect and corns
you know it's perfect and it's just it
looks exactly like it did in the movie
you know it was a pretty pretty cool
moment the biggest thing for me is I was
such a big baseball fan growing up I
mean honestly that's what I thought I
was gonna do with my life
you know all the way up until I
graduated from high school you know in
his case you have it he was a ballplayer
and he has the choice to stay there play
baseball or you know sort of come across
the line and never be able to go back
but has to save this child and and so
he's got a choice to make for me I think
a lot about when I graduated high school
playing baseball had the opportunity to
go to college and pursue a baseball
career or pursue music
to this day I love baseball but at the
same time it's like I chose to go with
music and put everything I had into that
career and obviously it's sort of led me
to where I am so it's worked out pretty
well but I think it's just one of those
things everybody always has a choice to
make makes or to reach that point and it
says sometimes those those choices are
what
this weather shakes your life hey what's
up everybody I'm Jason Aldean and I love
movies